we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P an
important voicemail question about Bernie
and his Judaism.
Let's take a listen.
Hello David Pakman.
This is Allen calling from Becky, one for
area code.
And my question for you is that if Bernie
Sanders does indeed get elected for president,
right, and given the fact that he would be
the first Jewish president, how likely is
it that he would be an immediate target for
assassination?
Oof.
Goodbye.
Yeah, so listen, there, uh, there has not
been that much overt antisemitism against
Bernie so far in the democratic primary, but
rest assured, we're not going to have to wait
too long for the antisemitism to become very
bold and blatant if indeed Bernie Sanders
is the nominate.
As far as assassination stuff, every president
deals with assassination threats.
Barack Obama saw a huge increase relative
to prior presidents.
Barack Obama, of course, the first black president.
There is no doubt that a secret service is
going to have its hands full with Bernie.
Even as the mere nominee, nevermind as president
of the United States, uh, that don't worry.
If you're waiting for the antisemitism, you're
going to see it.
It always is there a, when there is an opportunity
and Bernie Sanders has a nominee or president
would be a major, major opportunity.
I promise you that.
We are going to see it.
We've got a great bonus.
So for you, we will talk about the great airplane
seat reclining debate.
We will talk about Jeff Bezos is $10 billion
pledge to fight climate change and much, much
more.
Don't miss today's bonus show.
Get instant access to it by becoming a member
or a patron.
I'll see you then.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].